what is up everybody it's animak here
for anime
pro and today i will be breaking down
yet another
absolutely epic black clover chapter
the ultimate revenge match has just been
set up as the devil queen mangikula
faces off against the silva family
and their allies the final outcome
of the entire spade kingdom war arc
could be decided in this
very battle and things just keep getting
crazier and crazier so let's get into it
if you enjoy the black lover content on
this channel and you want us to keep it
going you know what to do just leave a
quick like
and comment it only takes a second but
it helps with the youtube algorithm
and of course if you're new to the
channel or you watch the channel but you
just haven't taken the time to subscribe
yet do me a favor and make this the
video that you subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on
all notifications you can also hit me up
on twitter and instagram
at animeopror finally this video will of
course contain
black clover manga spoilers so please
proceed with caution you have been
warned
alright so the latest chapter starts off
with asta expressing his amazement when
he sees noel's
saint stage form and noel then asks him
to
take care of loro while she takes on
megicula
man noel continues to be a true chadlass
and you love to see it we all kind of
expect the main character to show up and
save the day
in a shonen story and asta does do that
often
but at this point in the story hosta
succeeded in saving loro but he couldn't
do much
more than that so the other characters
including noel
have to step up and they've definitely
done that in a spectacular and
highly entertaining way by the looks of
it undine is right there with noel
which implies that noel is back in her
spirit
dive form in my previous video i
mentioned that i thought that maybe she
was using
saint stage without spirit dive because
her spirit dive timer ran
out a little while ago but it seems like
she is in spirit dive so maybe real's
twilight of valhalla
allowed noel to go back into spirit dive
at least for a little bit longer i will
assume that this is what happened unless
stated otherwise in order to get to
megicula
noel has to go through those weird dark
disciple zombies from the previous
chapter thankfully noel is being backed
up by
rilan charlotte continuing that nordic
walhalla theme
real creates a spell called lord of
walhalla
and this summons a giant odin like
figure who smashes a bunch of the
zombies using what looked to be
mini tornadoes i have to say that real's
magic
really is extremely cool both visually
and in terms of its potential effects
painting magic
just has so much potential and i'm glad
that we are now
finally seeing more of it real seems to
be mainly playing a supporting role
in this battle but that is totally fine
with me
that is what teamwork is all about and
not everyone on a team is going to go in
and attack the enemy directly at the
same time real has been doing a great
job supporting his allies in these last
few chapters
and he has made a real difference in
this fight already
even though he didn't really do any
direct damage to megicula
charlotte also manages to smash through
some of the zombies with her true briar
magic
and together noel rill and charlotte are
slowly opening up a path
to megicula for her part megicula
continues to be impressed by the
adaptability of humans during battle
and she seems to be having an absolute
blast toying with them
just as it looks like noel might
actually reach megicula
a bunch of giant zombies are summoned
and noel is nearly crushed by one of
them
thankfully before the giant zombie can
hurt noel
our boy luck voltea appears in his true
lightning magic mode
and he smashes the zombie into oblivion
luck tells noel that he will clear a
path for her straight to megicula and he
tells her to follow behind him
in that moment gaia reappears no
he's not dead because of course he's not
and he uses his
own lightning magic to help beat back
the zombies
even further now to be fair gaia does
say that he's already as good as dead
due to his injuries which suggests that
he might really die after this
battle is over but i honestly don't know
at this point
for all we know twilight of valhalla
might revive
gaia permanently or it could be just a
temporary extension of his life we'll
have to wait and see
the two lightning bros then start
absolutely smashing the zombies
as they clear a path towards megicula in
fact
their lightning attacks are so strong
that they tear right through the zombies
and they damage magikula herself
asta is amazed at how strong all of his
friends have become
and at this point in the story black
clover clearly wants to remind us that
the story itself
is not just about osta the protagonist
is not the only character who matters
the side characters have all been
improving they've all been getting
stronger and they all have an important
role to play
in this battle and in the story as a
whole
i mean just think back to what magna was
able to accomplish during this
spade kingdom war arc i don't think that
any of us had such high expectations
from magna but there you have it
i actually really like this and i
appreciate it because i'm generally not
a fan of series where one or two
characters do
literally everything and yeah everyone
else pretty much ends up being a
bystander
i'm not naming any names but i'm sure
that you guys can come up with some
examples of anime and manga that do this
in the comments below megikula's body
seems to have been destroyed by the
multiple lightning attacks launched by
lok and gaia
but thanks to her regeneration curse her
body begins to regenerate immediately
mekikula acknowledges that her current
form is still imperfect and so she is
nowhere near as strong as she could be
but even with that in mind she is still
really impressed by how well the humans
have fought
noel manages to push her way all the way
to megicula
but when she tries to stab magikula with
her sword megikula's curse
stops noel in her tracks and the sword
itself appears to have been destroyed
megikula tells noel that this is the
furthest
that she can go but then the one and
only nozzle
silva joins the fray he uses what looks
to be a new version of his silver star
of execution to seemingly trap megicula
inside this mercury creation magic spell
nozelle then speaks directly to megicula
proclaiming yet again you dared to show
yourself
before my family how i have longed
for this moment and that is how this
epic
and action-packed chapter ends after all
these years
it's finally time for revenge now we
know that noel wants revenge against
magikula for killing her mother
but don't forget that noel was just a
baby when her mother died so she
probably has no memory
of what actually happened that day but
noesel was older at the time so you
better believe that he remembers his
mother's death at the hands of vanica
and megicula and he probably remembers
it
very vividly he witnessed it all
directly
and i'm sure that this memory has
haunted him for all these years
if anyone wants revenge even more than
noel does
if anyone takes this even more
personally than noel
it is nosel nozzle has been waiting for
this moment for like 16 or 17
years i'm sure that he's been training
like crazy during the time skip
preparing for this exact scenario
and now he is here along with his sister
noel and
all the others and i'm sure that noesel
is about to go
all out whoa this is shaping up to be
one of the most
satisfying revenge moments in anime
history
obviously we don't know how this battle
is ultimately going to end
but after learning what we learned about
ossier and how she died
i think that all of us would love to see
the silvas successfully avenging their
mother
but since we don't actually know how the
battle will end the big question is what
happens next will nozelle noel
real charlotte luck and gaia be enough
to defeat megicula
it sure seems like all of them working
together could actually take her down
and if asta manages to go back into his
devil union mode for even a few seconds
in the near future
it could be curtains for megicula but at
the same time
megikula is far from being at full power
if she can find a way to get even
stronger
maybe by finally finishing vanica off
then
all options would be back on the table
it definitely looks like makikula is
losing control of the battlefield at
this moment
but we simply cannot count her out
especially knowing how incredibly tricky
and versatile
curse magic is let me know what you guys
think
are you excited that nosel and luck have
joined the battle
and do you think that the silvas are
about to avenge their mother after
all these years can the silvas and their
allies really take magikula out
or is she still too strong for them
finally
do you think that we are ever going to
see mkikula in her
perfect form or does the fact that asta
managed to save loro means that megicula
will never get to manifest
fully into this world don't forget to
leave your feedback
down in the comments below if you
enjoyed this video and you want to see
more black clover content right here on
the channel
leave a quick like and comment it only
takes a second but it helps a lot
and if you're new to the channel or
maybe you watch the channel but you
haven't subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications you really have to go
through the trouble of subscribing
hitting the bell
and then selecting the option that says
all if you don't do that you're still
going to miss a ton of our videos even
if you are subscribed
it's just how youtube works you can also
hit me up on twitter and instagram
at animeopror i want to give a big thank
you to all of our anime uproar patrons
for making videos like this one possible
special thank you to alpha sigma he is
an absolute mad lad and disciple
of lord twego himself and i can't forget
all of our
the one tier patrons the ones who rise
above all
other clans including ingrata pate heffa
al jatal hirokami and water the toasted
chi the spike
emperor otaku spidey life chanel
tungsten tarcus baked buddhist cody
hebert
and monkey d quilly finally thank you
also to our pro hero tier patrons
including the one and only gilgamesh the
red haired raven angel crews rather in
deora very gucci
alicia octor bonnie parks joy and garcia
techno ted fat boy games corey mcgowan
and soul ray slice and dice
if you enjoy our videos and you feel
that they provide value to you consider
supporting us
on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patreon exclusive
discord and your name will appear in our
videos
along with these legendary people as
always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you